- [Narrator] Since the 15th century,
the Tatra Mountains in
Poland have been home
to a very special type of
handmade cheese, oscypek.
Authentic versions of
this milky, smoky cheese
are only made in this region, usually in
(speaking in foreign language)
cheese huts.
And Janina is one of its makers.
She is a baca.
- [Narrator] In oscypek tradition,
its maker is usually a man,
and the secret process is
passed down from father to son.
However, Janina broke from the mold,
becoming one of the only female masters.
- [Narrator] And this milk is
sacred for authentic oscypek,
which requires at least
60 percent sheep's milk.
Everything from the grass they eat
to how cold they get
is a concern for Janina
and those who help her.
(gentle instrumental music)